okay so this is actually joint work with
some of my students I have listed up
there and you know feel free free to ask
questions as I as I go through the talk
so there's been a lot of emphasis both
at this workshop and more generally on
the use of you know large clusters and
you know tools such as MapReduce to deal
with lodge data and I think there's been
a little bit less emphasis on deciding
when is it really appropriate to use
these large clusters and certainly in
some cases it is but some cases it's not
and what can be done on something that's
a little bit smaller and so something
that smaller might be a laptop or it
might be a desktop or it might be a
server so nowadays you can go off and in
fact you can go in the web right now and
go to the dell site and you can buy a
server with 64 cores on it and two
terabytes of memory and 20 terabytes of
disk or more back probably the disk is
pretty much unlimited you know for about
fifteen twenty thousand dollars okay so
that's not a lot of money for a
reasonably powerful machine so how far
can those go and I think that's an
interesting question what are the
potential advantage of using these
machines well one it's just cost another
one is that they tend to be much more
energy efficient on a per cycle basis so
if we look at some computation you want
to do in a big server versus a little
machine you're probably gonna be using
much less energy for the same
computation more cost-effective and
another key point is that they're
typically much easier to program okay
they typically have a shared memory
model and i'll be talking about this
today and they particularly much easier
for more journal class so you don't have
to restrict yourself to things that only
map to MapReduce so only map to pray
goal only map to some restricted class
and model they're very they're really
general purpose machines you can mix you
know your string processing with your
divide and conquer with your you know
all sorts of different flavors and they
all fit together nicely and there's well
known parallel algorithms etc they're
also easier to amend min
stir and more reliable one of these
servers once you boot it they typically
stay up for years on end they are very
very very rarely crash so there's not
really a question of even needing to
deal the fault tolerance is done in the
hardware that the memories fault
tolerant and there's all sorts of port
orleans built in so but why do why might
we use a large cluster well often the
reason cited the data just doesn't fit
in the memory of you know a single
machine of some flavor and the other is
just processing speed okay so let's sort
of address some of these and if you go
look at a lot of the articles about big
data and you know where the big data
comes from and there's been all sorts of
articles or you can even go to the
wikipedia page and they'll list all
sources sorts of sources are very big
data often the almost the top of the
list oasis things like this slow and sky
survey that's generating some huge
amounts of data the Large Hadron
Collider with all sorts of senses
generating data you know very high rates
there's Walmart which is the biggest you
know retailer in the world and they have
and they've been for many many years
collecting every menisci o piece of data
they possibly can very detailed of
course then there's just YouTube there's
a lot of videos on YouTube and you can
sort of look at the frame average bytes
per frame and calculate how many total
bytes there's on YouTube and then you
could imagine and we don't have this yet
but you can imagine someday we have the
human genome sequence for every human
okay I don't know if I want them to have
mine but if they did you know that's a
relatively large amount of data so these
are all relatively large sets of data
but then you have to ask yourself well
you know how much of that's really
relevant so it turns out the [ __ ] Sloan
sides Sky Survey they throw away
ninety-nine point nine percent of that
data that's coming in okay it's it's
very rough in the Large Hadron Collider
it turns out most of those centers on a
tiny tiny fraction of a nonzero at any
time so just the most trivial form of so
when they calculate these things they
sort of just multiply the number of
sensors by the
you know rate of those senses and that
gives you a number right but yeah that's
not the real question is you know how
much useful information is it in there
in walmart well probably if you're going
to be doing some sort of statistical
analysis of walmart like i said this
date of walnut collects every single
little thing about not just sales
receipts it collects i know the
temperature of their stores at any given
time you know they got sensors on all
their different refrigerators and all
sorts of different things you're
probably going to be looking at some
slice of it and maybe that's light is
big oh maybe it's not so I'm not going
to claim that this is always going to
fit in some smaller memory but you have
to be aware that that's sort of an upper
bound this if you've looked at
everything that will not ever touched
youtube well probably you're not going
to just bring in all the YouTube videos
and process them well maybe there might
be a couple people who want to do that
more likely is you're going to extract
features from those videos and then you
know do some analysis that those feature
vectors and so the feature vectors would
be very much smaller and then you know
the total size of the video and the
genome well first of all a lot of that's
repeat 99% of some huge percent of our
genomes are repeated and Nonie that but
there's all sorts of smart compression
you could do so it's not actually clear
how much information that really is in
the human genome you can't just multiply
the number of people by the size that
would be very silly way to store but
let's look at some particular types of
data so let's look at web grass look at
how big web graphs are you know where we
could fit them nowadays so there's a
great i should say graphs in general
this is just an example of graph so
there's been a lot of emphasis on large
grass so we can go out there and say
well how big of the grass which are
available nowadays well first thing to
note is for us poor people in academia
it turns out we can't get a hold on very
big graphs at least I can and if first
request I have is if any of you have
bigger graphs I can get a hold of I
would be delighted get get them okay so
the biggest graph I've been able to get
ahold of are around
six billion edges so there's a yahoo
sample graph there's also a UK web graph
they're both about the same size at UK's
five and a half billion edges he owes a
little bit over six billion edges and
you know that's that's we can get in
academia I've been told that there's
much bigger graphs and you know in
industry that's a Twitter graph I
believe that's the follower graph which
this is the number i got last spring
maybe it's a bit bigger now there's a
Facebook sort of friends graph and these
are these are just numbers that I've
been whispered to because they all
propriety information so not only can I
not get the grass I can't even get the
size of them and then you can sort of
look at there's a lot of junk on the web
if you throw away the complete junk you
can get various estimates and it's you
know on the order of 200 billion and so
that's the size and then if you look at
how big it would be to compress or those
at least if you're just storing the
graph structure itself the vertices and
the edges then that's about the number
of bytes you need and in fact today i'll
talk a little bit about graph
compression if i get to it and you can
actually get about a factor of 10
improvement in size by using some
relatively simple graph compression
techniques so if you can press those
those those are sort of the sizes of
graphs ok and those are the biggest
graphs I can get ahold of the active on
the relatively small size some of you
probably have access to some of these
bigger ones you can also look a text and
there's lat various sources of text you
can go to JSTOR which is as most of you
know a collection of journal articles a
very broad collection this is the one
that was involved in that controversy at
MIT whether the full student got sent to
jail I was about to be sent to jail for
taking some of them there's pubmed which
is it's got more documents but each one
smallest is about the same amount of sir
same size then there's a library of
congress and you can just count the
number of volumes and take an average of
the number of characters per volume and
then you can assume you can compress it
and that's about the size so that's
about the limit of
next okay on the order of a terabyte
okay well now let's look at what's
available in different machines okay so
we've got various flavors of machines we
have laptops I got the price there I'm
assuming for the main memory that you've
pretty much loaded it okay now some of
these machines taking a little bit more
than that memory but you take a laptop
and you you fill it with memory you can
get 10 gigabytes nowadays you can put a
bit more than that you can get a desktop
you can put a hundred and I think most
of them sort of limited 128 gigabytes or
you can get one of these servers these
are typically rack mounted servers you
know about this big and they go up to in
fact some of them go up to two terabytes
nowadays and probably if you asked the
company that would do your favor and put
a little bit more than that in so this
is a physical memory and then you can
look at the secondary memory which is
the disks and then that's about two
orders larger in magnitude and phase
actually just pretty much unlimited you
could put a lot more but at some point
the there's only so much information you
get on and off of it so it doesn't
really pay off and then that number of
course so that's number processing units
these typically have so if we took look
something like the Twitter graph and map
that on like I say that's a lot bigger
than I can get a hold of its you know it
fits on everything in yellow that's it
so it fits right so it's fits on a
server it doesn't quite fit on the
desktop into the memory of the server
okay and you know because I can get this
terabyte so you can get in there now
like I say this is just the graph you
might have some auxiliary information so
depending on what you're doing with it
you know maybe doesn't fit but a lot of
the things we've been talking about the
last couple days like I know a triangle
counting all you really need is a graph
structure you know keeping anything
anything around or even page rank and a
lot of these graph analysis or between
the centrality typically all you need is
the grass structure and maybe a little
bit of data per vertex in between the
centrality have to keep it like a
floating point number on each vertex
there's not that much more the ancillary
data so this is so the claim is and if
we compress it we could even squeeze it
on to a desktop okay these we can get
another factor of 10 and once again
you'd have to look at what auxiliary
data you're keeping and whether you can
press the auxiliary data as well to
really figure this out but at least as a
you know sort of first cut so the point
is that we can pick pretty big graphs
certainly on a you know $20,000
rack-mounted server with 64 course so
then the question is well what can we do
you know what's the performance compared
to you know your favorite you know graph
processing library on such a server and
that's one of the things I'll talk about
today so in particular what I'm going to
talk about in the rest of the talk here
is I'm going to talk first about a
little bit about what sorts of
generality so the claim is the shared
memory servers you could much more
flexible in the time sorts of programs
you can put on them you're not limited
to just that something that fits onto
MapReduce something that fits onto
Prairie goal something that you know
whatever your favorite library is there
really general purpose machines there's
been a lot of experience on developing
parallel algorithms with these there's
parallel algorithms with just about
anything you can think of on these sorts
of machines I'll talk about a particular
craft processing thing that we've mapped
on to shared memory machines and compare
them to other graph processing libraries
I'll talk about this is another extreme
is what about if you're talking about
really if you really want to run your
Twitter graph on a laptop you'd have to
go to disk and so one of my students has
developed a system that works can
process very large graphs on a laptop
and we'll look at sort of the
performance characteristics of that and
if I get to it i'll talk a little bit
about that gat graph compression and how
you can get basically a fact of 10 feel
without that complicated methods
compression on a graph so you could put
much larger graphs on on smaller
memories so the first topic was the you
know what can you program on these
machine
but I'm assuming now one of these
servers it's a shared memory server they
typically have up to 64 processes on
maybe four chips or eight chips every
year the scale nowadays you can connect
Xeon Phi you can actually get 80 cores
on on one chimp and you know so soon
we're going to happen is going to have a
few hundred cores in a shared memory
system the nice thing about these shared
memories it's very easy to write the
general purpose they allow you to do
nested parallelism well talk about that
a little bit pipeline parallelism they'd
allow you to build all sorts of very
complicated pointer structures you're
not just limited to graphs you can have
trees you have trees with grass you can
of graphs that have sub trees you're
going to hypergraphs you know anything
you can possibly think of as a point of
structure and you don't need to a
separate library for each one of these
things you know tree library a graph
library for them there's lots of
understanding there's been 30 years of
development of parallel algorithms 40
years for these sorts of shared memory
machines so there's algorithms with just
about anything you can think about that
and we've done a lot of experiments they
actually quite reasonably fast I'll talk
about some of them they have simple cost
models and programming is relatively
easy so here's just an example of a
parallel program that you might wreck
right that map's very easily onto a
shared memory machine so this is
quicksort you might have been taught it
as a sequential program but it's really
a parallel piece of code a parallel
algorithm so what does it do and this is
an example of what i call nested
parallelism so it's a way that basically
i can take a something it's parallel and
then make multiple calls to other things
which are parallel okay so quick salt
here it says if the size is less than or
equal to 1 I just return the result
otherwise I pick a random pivot and I
pick the elements which less than the
pivot equal to the pivot and greater I
recursively solve the ones which are
less and greater and then I put the
results together ok so there's old your
understanding this is actually in a real
peril language called Nestle and then
you ask well how much parallelism is
there but there's a lot of parallelism
this a huge amount of parallelism
because when you compare the keys to the
pivots that can all be done in parallel
so you can basically sub select all the
ones less equal greater in a very highly
parallel way and then there's a very
quite different kind of parallelism
which is some people would call task
parallelism as I can make the two
recursive calls to quicksort and
parallel and of course that Forks off
you get a whole tree of recursive calls
which eventually which gets done in
parallel there's a lot of parallelism
the sub selection of the elements equal
greater and less that sort of it's sort
of a data parallel that can be done very
easily in MapReduce you could have a
MapReduce that basically collects up the
ones which are less equal and greater
that's pretty straightforward the other
kind that's task parallelism that can't
be done in in in any of the most of
these libraries you know MapReduce pig
you know you name it this is a can't be
done in these sorts of libraries but
this is a very simple piece of code you
can code it up and it actually runs
reasonably efficient lame parallel we've
code this up you get something that's
basically within a factor of 2 of the
very fastest parallel gurlitt's that's
out there which is a sample based sort
it also can be analyzed this is supposed
to sort of show the dag of the
computation so the left hand is when you
split it in two so this shows time along
the x-axis here and the mound of
parallel work along the y-axis so you
can sub select the elements less than
the pivot on the very top in parallel
you make the two recursive calls they
can also they run in parallel in
addition within each of them there's
parallelism so that's why it is called
nested parallelism and this works its
way on and so if you look at the
so-called span or the critical path or
the depth of the computation it's it's
you know Polly logarithmic it's
something like log squared and it's so
the tree is log n deep and each of those
blocks is log in in order to do the
packing down and the total amount of
work is n log N and it turns out you can
also analyze this cache come complexity
of this algorithm as discussed in one of
the talks yesterday and that this turns
out to be an optimal measuring cap so
these all with their since its quicksort
with random pivots these are all with
high probability
bounce the point is you can analyze it
you can code it the code is short you
can run it and it runs efficiently and
it's you know it's not the sort of thing
that you can do with MapReduce and you
might say well quicksort who cares about
quicksort but it's you know this sort of
recursive divide and conquer is also
applicable in a lot of machine learning
types of algorithms so here's just a
classification tree I'm trying to build
a decision tree and typically what you
do is you would you know you take in
your if you've got a set of attribute
value vectors one of which your
conditioning on so you're trying to
classify based on one of these in this
case it happens to be the last element
of that vector you basically figure out
which of the other attributes give you
the most in correlating most highly with
that that attribute you split on that
and then you recurse on the subsets
these now you've split on that one
attribute you've created a bunch of
packets now for each of those buckets
you want to decide what's the next most
important attribute okay and this
actually has very similar structure to
the quicksort is a divide and conquer
algorithm you can do this conditional
entropy thing patent parallel like I
said that sort that sort of thing would
be very easy to do in MapReduce but then
when you make the recursive calls you've
got multiple calls to the same algorithm
cut here on those subsets which could be
highly different sizes and so you can't
just put one on each processor that oops
and then you know so you want to
basically do that in parallel and again
this is very straightforward on a on a
shared memory machine and there's also
so they were just talking about the
structure of the computation then there
you also want to build various data
structures I thought I'd take cover
trees out I massive Jones in the
audience here but it's a basically tree
that's used to do sort of nearest
neighbor searches in metric spaces it
doesn't require an embedding in
Cartesian space you can basically build
these trees and then you can do searches
on it the point being first of all you
can build the tree very easily in fact
the algorithms do this in parallel is
that's almost trivial in a shared memory
machine but you can also then represent
this complicated data structure and you
can search it and these sorts of things
are not natural and I know Matt produces
sort of you just process a bunch of data
and then throw it away you know build
data structures and process those eight
descriptions or suffix tree is another
thing that we've looked at is that you
know it's an affluent method for storing
long strings so you can very quickly do
all sorts of queries like you searches
on them find common sub sequences etc
and it's relatively complicated
sophisticated algorithm especially the
parallel version and got also to divide
and conquer in it it's got all sorts of
components again it's not that
complicated due on a shared memory
machine and you can get you know
reasonably good speed up not these sorts
of machines okay so that that's just
what you argue that you know these in
some sense they're more general purpose
that you don't you don't have to then
restrict yourself to your your ex
library in order to do this you've got a
general-purpose programming model the
next thing that's going to do is talk
about a particular graph analysis oh we
wanted to see what sort of performance
you could get on and flexibility you
could get in
on a shared memory machine so we
developed with student Julian this ligar
base so let me just talk a little bit
about that so it stands for lightweight
graph processing system lightweight here
just means it's not very many lines of
code in a thousand five hundred lines of
code and an important aspect with this
is that it's very easy to mix with any
other to the C++ based thing it's not
like a special-purpose language you can
throw in your suffolk street code and
link it in with it and you know take the
graph and output in and you know it's
all in the same environment so that's
all nice and convenient it's a simple
framework two routines and one data
structure i'll describe these parallel
describe and the point is that we you
know it's efficient it outperforms most
of these graph libraries like Perry Gaul
etc in particular outperforms I'm using
just a 40 core server not needing
compared to you know hundreds of course
on these other systems and I'll give you
some numbers it's the interfaces it's
also more flexible in the sense that it
allows you something like prego allows
you to turn vertices off and on it's a
most of you might know Perry goal it's a
graph representation tool allows you to
turn vertices off and on here we allow
basically arbitrary vertex we have a
concept of vertex subset and you could
have multiple them around you could have
vertex a B and C in one set and the
verdict subset is it separate from the
graph so you have your graph data and
then a vertex a subset that's completely
separate for it's not like in prego
where it's part of the graph is a little
bit of state that says whether where the
vertex is on or off so if this allows
you to have an arbitrary number of them
and it gives you know sort of modularity
because you don't have to mess up your
graph representation you can also have
multiple graphs around you might have so
common thing we found is you might have
the same set of vertices but in some
cases you've got red edges in some cases
you got blue edges and sometimes you
want to process the red edges and
sometimes a blue so you just have two
graphs around with the same vertices
and you got the red and the blue and you
can have any mixture of these and you
can use the same vertex subset for those
two graphs etc so it's you know it's
just because it's a shared memory you
can any of these things are just
perfectly natural then the two routines
of basic vertex map so if it's just Maps
some function over the vertices ok it
doesn't map the function over the output
edges so unlike a graph lab of prey goal
which when you say vertex map you mean
typically mean do something with the
output edges there's a separate edge map
which then maps all all the edges so you
can say something mapple all over the
edges and exam and an advantage of this
edge map is that it can be in parallel
so for example if you had a graph which
at very high degree particularly could
have a vertex that connects to every
other vertex ok most of these other
systems you'd have to process the edges
out of that vertex sequentially and so
it's not you sort of bounded by the
highest degree as amount of parallelism
you can get here the acts of the
processing over the edges is itself
parallel so I'd give just a quick
example of how you might apply this to
breadth first search fact with the
original motivation for this is the
graph 500 benchmark which is a graph
benchmark developed in the
supercomputing community and we were
trying to get the there's very highly
tuned one for these shared memory
machines and we're trying to get the
sort of same performance with very
simple code anyway so breath for a
search you started some source you
basically search out to all the
neighbors you find everyone that's one
away ok and then from there so we go and
find everyone that's we mark them all we
then look at all the outer edges some of
them will have already been visited so
some of them might point back to our I
guess in this graph they don't but some
like point within all the ones that
haven't been visited you go add to the
next so-called frontier what's important
here is each frontier is a so-called
vertex a subset right it's a subset of
all the vertices so now model this would
just be we'd have some representation
for that subset of vertices we would
then map over the the outer edges of
those
cease to get the next set and add them
to the next frontier okay so that just
continues until you've explored all the
graph the other nice point about this is
you can actually see in this model you
can store some some algorithms what they
do is they go one direction on these
breathless searches and then they have
to basically go backwards so that
between the centrality algorithm does
that and so you just store the vertex
subsets on a linked list right you eat
one of them and then when you go
backwards you just pull the first one
out put them on a stack basically pull
them out reverse order this all just you
know basic programming okay this is what
the code would look like for that that
thing it's in a C++ syntax but other
than that it's pretty much what's shown
here all this says is this is the edge
map and what edge map does is it takes a
graph it takes the vertex subset and it
says map over all the outer edges of
that protects subset a particular
function in this case the function is
this update which is going to grab the
next frontier and then it also takes a
conditional that says you only apply
this thing if this is conditional true
so in particular only apply if it hasn't
already been visited that's what that
comes in there and if it has already
what you do is this compare and swap
which is an atomic operation which
basically updates this parents array so
that the yet the actual goal here by the
way is to build a DFS tree so each each
node points to its parent and this in
the DFS so what that does and it also
returns a value here which says whether
you want to keep it in the next vertex
subset so only if the compare-and-swap
succeeds you add it to the next vertex
subset and that's what's then finally
returned here is frontier okay so that's
sort of what a code would look like okay
the there's actually this is a thing as
we were trying to compete with these the
grass 500 code and it turns out this
this very cute technique that was
developed actually here at Berkeley by a
group the student here is Beamer that
did a lot of the work and it's a
technique that basically says if the the
number of vertices is very small then
you want to sparse representation of
those vertices you want to basically
only operate on on the vertices in the
frontier okay if the number is
relatively large and the large being
about in practice is about ten percent
or more you actually want to go the
opposite direction you basically want to
look at all the vertices and read from
the vertex upset and they use a sort of
bit mask representation for the vertex
subset I'm not going to go in detail
this but it turns out that this is a
gets you a lot of emission see
improvement and then we face we
basically compete with the very highly
optimized code of beamer and patterson
which is quite messy code let me just
skip this so we you know we run
experiments on this we read bro in a
bunch of different algorithms I'll list
them in a second we use run the
experiment on the largest graph we could
get hold of which is about 6.6 billion
edges this very easily fits in one of
these is just a picture of what are
these one of these rack mounted service
look like okay this true in fact we
probably could have fit something 10
times as big on this and like I said
this is like a four chip system here
with this particular one has 40 cause
and like this is yes we implemented in
the parallelism comes from a library
called silk plus which is actually now
part of the new release if you go get
the new janu g a c++ compiler it has
these parallel primitives built in to it
as of just this month i believe well
maybe it's coming out next week or
something use this 40 cool machine we
get
good speed ups on page rank we actually
get almost perfect speed up if it's just
a comparison on a few of the different
algorithms we compared to some other
codes that we found out there K DT s
actually a system I guess was described
yesterday knowledge discovery tool kit
power graph was also described prego
many of you might know as a system
originally suggested at Google and
there's been various implementations so
if you look at the like breadth-first
search well you know we quite you know
four five times faster on you know many
fewer so it's 40 cause instead of 240
courts so again if you're looking at
cost effectiveness or energy
effectiveness you have to multiply the
difference and number of cores by the
difference in performance get the
overall cost advantage so it would be I
know what a 4 x 6 or something you know
between the centrality you can compare
it pagerank I should point out
everyone's done page rank you know that
you can find implementations as
discussed in the talk yesterday page
power graph just blows away all the
previous ones okay so if you look at a
dupe and etc so the PageRank nut for
power graph is 3.6 in fact now I think
it's a little bit better than that and
so if it's you know blows away these
other things but we're basically
competitive okay they basically the
times here about the same the difference
here is with this is 40 cause vs. 240
course
well my get argument is I can't find it
yeah okay if you can give me a graph
that doesn't fit in our system then
that's true okay I i just i discern the
grass i can get a couple orders of
magnitude at least one order of
magnitude from not being able to fit the
graphs in that these other companies
have are probably closer to that that
border right but like I said these these
servers but you can you can probably
know going to expand quite rapidly soon
right so my question is just let's
analyze sure that I'm sure their graphs
that don't fit but we should think about
which grass fit in which ones don't yeah
so but to take your highest level point
yes maybe it's unfair to do a comparison
here but the issue is do we need to go
to these more general purpose I guess
the shortest paths there's a in the
original prego paper and this might be
unfair because that was a very first
prego paper maybe they've optimize the
system's a lot since then but you know
it's again this is on three hundred
multi-core so I think that's a thousand
two hundred cause total versus 40 cause
and and ten times slower so anyway so
it's lightweight simple efficient and
like I said a lot of the advantage here
does come on the fact that we're doing
it on shared memory okay so as soon as
you go to distributed memory the
overheads of transmitting messages
across these things becomes much more
expensive the the flexibility you have
becomes less so then the question is
really what can we do on shared memory
some future work is what we're currently
working on is the fact is not limiting
to here is is actually using the
compressed representation of grass so
that we can store even bigger graphs
okay the other work that
student oppo heroic worked on is this
question of well what could you do on a
very small machine like a laptop you
know could we process very large grass
how slow would it be so in this case
we're not going to compete with the very
fastest systems out there but I guess
what this shows is that you can actually
process you know relatively large graphs
on a small machine maybe not quite as
fast on lodging machines but that's a
result it's this book actually sort of a
piggy backs there's been a whole bunch
of work on sort of disk based algorithms
for for graph processing in the theory
community there's been a lot of work and
elsewhere this particular system is
basically what it does is it's a vertex
based system in fact it's quite simple
similar graph lab where you basically
each vertex does something with its set
of neighbors on each iteration and
updates the the vertex based on its
neighbors or updates the actually the
outer edges based on the current value
of out edges it turns out that this
particular method only has to pass over
the data once per per iteration it
requires that the memories about a least
square root of n of the size of the
total graph ok and that's almost trivial
even if you can think of very very very
big graphs square root of n should fit
in the in the memory it breaks it up
into shards so these are the vertices
and the idea is that each shot is going
to be loaded into memory you process
shards the shards are basically sorted
by n edges so the way when you process a
vertex you're going to send some
information on out all the outer edges
which are going to be the input to
images on another charge possibly but
because they are sorted by n edges
they're going to be adjacent in the
other shot so you can think of this as
if we had it on disk all of our axis of
sequential accesses so I basically load
this shot into memory and it's a bunch
of sequential accesses and then when I
right
out I'm going to write out contiguously
along each of those red blocks some of
the outer edges from Thea sod1 are going
to go to shod what going to go to itself
some are going to go to sha to some
we're going to show three but when I
write them out they're going to be
contiguous so it means basically I do a
single pass over the things fact I
basically do one right right of each
block and then a read because when I
write it out 2-shot to i'm going to
write it and then when I process shot do
i'm going to read that again and then
you process the next shot and it's going
to write continuous blocks within each
of those so they've done basically a poe
wrote a whole bunch of different
applications on top of this a lot of
these since he's also involved in the
graph lab project came from the craft
lab project and there's in order to
create the shards there's some amount of
pre-processing time to break them up and
sort them and everything so it's that
you know it's not completely trivial so
the biggest graph again we have is this
Yahoo web you know it takes half an hour
just to pre-process this graph who wants
its pre-processed then you can do these
iterations in parallel and so this is
just on a mac mini you know that's one
of these things you know oops with 8
gigabytes of RAM you know it's
relatively small SSD and a intel this is
a full core machine if you look at the
times here you can compare them to Grass
lab times and like I said for pagerank
GraphLab and I'll Agra about the same ok
so this is not as fast it's 40 times
slower but you're doing it on a laptop
you know like well at mac mini not a
laptop but basically equivalent to
laptop so you know these are the sorts
of times you can get a triangle counting
is is about 30 times its on GraphLab is
about 30 times faster than graph try so
it's it's this this is a disk based
version is 30 times slower but what it
shows is that you could if you were I
don't know a student and all you had
access to with a mac mini and you could
put up with with a little bit more time
you could process these graphs on it you
know there's a reasonable size graph
with six billion edges there's also you
could imagine techniques that we've been
looking at way you use a mix of disk
space algorithms especially if you have
exhilarate data that doesn't fit into
your memory but the main graph does you
can imagine storing the auxiliary data
out of memory and only scanning it when
you touch those vertices if you touch
them in order and you know you could get
some sort of mix here we haven't
actually tried this in future work okay
the last topic I wanted to talk about is
in memory compression I think this is an
approach that could be used to lots of
data structures if you want to store a
very large data in memory what we're
looking at here is not just you know
come only when you think of compression
you think of I know storing a image out
to disk or something and the point is in
order to read that image you have to
fully uncompress it okay the goal here
is to basically store data in memory in
a compressed form such that you can get
random access to it okay so the goal is
I want to say access vertex 27 and give
me the list of its neighbors okay and
you know what I basically have to
decompress the whole graph to do that
you want to basically just do that as
fast as random access in fact the
interesting thing here is we found that
you can actually it's a little bit
faster if you do the compressed format
because the memory footprint is less so
you're going to as you for example
access your your neighbor list in this
compressed format you in a hit less
cache line
because it's been compressed down to
something smaller and the idea is pretty
simple this is actually work I student
minded many years ago took over 10 years
ago is that Yuri number vertices using
so-called graph separators so graph
separator is a partition of the graph
which you're trying to find a petition
into about half and half vertices does
that be exactly half and half that's the
number of edges you cut is relatively
small okay and it's well known that a
lot of real world grass that's
reasonably small separators because you
know you think of communities let's say
it's a web graph you know the CMU set of
pages is pretty much self referential it
has some locality to it so the number of
edges that you cut if you separate CMU
graph from the rest of the world is much
less than you'd expect in a random graph
okay and that's when this this technique
works well and so you renumber the
vertices so they have this locality so
for example we remember all the CMU
vertices so that they're near each other
and then we DIF encode the edges okay so
the idea is you take your graph you
finds cuts and you actually do this
recursively until your debt left with
either to leave for very small
components and then you just give an
order number into the vertices so I
would you know number of these you know
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten etc along that way so now the
idea is that vertices which are near
each other in the graph which will be
ended up with these components will have
numbers which are close to each other
okay then what you do is you encode an
edge by instead of saying this if this
is a pointer for my don't over text
seven million three hundred whatever it
is to some other random number is you
encode the difference so if this is if
these two vertices only differ by seven
they're very close to each other then
you encode that seven and it turns out
that there's lots of codes which you can
use which use very few bits if the
numbers are small okay and so this is
just an example ivory number this graph
so it has locality right be 0 1 2 3 so
the numbers which are close to each
other close
graph we then write out the adjacency
lists so this particular vertex 4 has
four neighbors which are two three five
and six and we encode them by first we
take the difference between the vertex
form the first one which is negative 2
first one is the only one that can be
negative and then we put them in
increasing order so the difference
between four between two and three is
one between three and five is 2x cetera
and so now what we have to do to encode
my out list is just encode these numbers
and these numbers are small and so i can
use very small small number of bits in
it so the point is it's really just like
an adjacency list I just put them you
know in a cache line one after each
other except I only need a few bits per
edge here and I then just randomly
access the vertex and from that it turns
out to be quite fast to decode these
these codes it's a very quick table
lookup and doesn't involved any more
cache misses it's just a bit operations
basically there's also a theory behind
here that says that if if the graph
happens to have good separators in
particular if you can find a cut we're
less than n a polynomial e less so end
to the you know point 7 or point A to
point 9 edges are cut then the total
number of bits you'll need for this
representation is is order n ok for
random graph you can prove you're always
going to meet n log n bits because every
point it takes about log n bits in the
Zen of them m of them in this case you
you can reduce that to give you a sense
of how it works and practice how many
bits you can get these are the bit
counts I I wouldn't worry about the TD
here that's the time for for generating
the the ordering the petitioners and
what these are a three different
separator code this is Metis I don't
know if any of you heard of métis it's
the most popular graph separator code
out there it's very very widely used
listings I'm to the community computing
community we use that that's pretty
expensive I guess that's what that 153
then we use some sort of much faster
versions of separators which didn't
quite do as well in general in some
although in some cases they did better
and what they gave perfectly
no compression these dumb Bahia bits
parech okay so these are actually some
basically grass from scientific
computing up here visa maps this is a
pennsylvania street map the california
street map these are small samples of
google of a google a web graph that
we've got from google while ago and this
is here is the number of bits per edge
so what it says is we can basically take
and the google on google is the
basically it's a directed graph so this
is the in edges and the outer edges it
turns out that because you can have many
more in edges and out edges it's
actually more and efficient to represent
the images than the outer edges he's a
degree the out degree is not very high
but the in do complete can be very high
so that's the number of f bits per edge
to encode it using our most efficient so
you can see it's only 46 and now in
practice what we typically do is we
always round up to a bite so we always
store use at least one bite so if this
would be at least you know eight bits
but the point is we get down an edge
down to about one bite so if you now
want to do a back-of-the-envelope
calculation of how big of a graph you
can fit in your memory okay again you
might have auxiliary data calculate that
separate and add it on but just for the
graph the edge and vertex that's wrapped
and you just want to ask yourself how
big of a graph can I fit in my memory a
rough rule and you're going to use
compression a rough rule of thumb will
be one bike parech okay so if you have a
billion edges that will figure it big in
a bit fit in a gigabyte and could it fit
on your laptop okay if you have 10
billion edges then you will maybe build
a lot of memory in your laptop but
beyond that it's any top anyway so they
are these graph compression techniques
they apply to different sorts of graphs
they're not specific to just web graphs
they apply disease a scientific
computing map graphs web graphs this is
a lucent this is a graph of the routers
that y is between routers on lucent so
that some and i forget what the scan
graph is here okay so i guess the
conclusion is for many applications
large data
maybe your will fit in memory I'm not
going to promise you it always fits in
memory but I think it's at least worth
making a back-of-the-envelope
calculation take the ID number of edges
in your graph you know do the
calculation you know maybe decide
whether you're willing to write the
compression code or not and you know
there's a factor of ten to one between
those but you can sort of calculate
what's going to fit and then the
argument it set once if it does fit in
the shared memory this there is a big
programming advantage which is you don't
have to make these special purpose
libraries you have a general-purpose
programming model where you can mix you
can create complicated point2 structures
trees and graphs and mixes of them you
can have nested parallelism you know
pipeline parallelism all these things
the code is typically simple and more
general you know a lot of the let these
high-level libraries like mapreduce they
they're actually very simple also
because they're limited ok but under the
hood they're very complicated so maybe
this is i should say if you want to do
right really optimized code it's gonna
be simple more general and probably if
you wanted to just calculate what's the
most energy efficient way to do these
graph calculations and time matted with
secondary you'd probably figure out one
of these disk based algorithms is the
most efficient okay so maybe it's 30
times slower and maybe you're not
willing to put up with that but if you
are you've got this you could do it on a
laptop that you know you can run on a
battery you know you probably be however
many the few hours it takes to run maybe
you'll run out of your battery because
it's running at a hundred peak but you
know you it's not going to take that
much electricity so but you know often
you want results faster and then you
might want to go up to a somewhat more
powerful system okay so that's all I was
going to say
you